[Music]
first of all I'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to this
wonderful workshop really a pleasure to
be here so I'm going to talk about
adaptive sampling in matrix completion
I'm very happy that you should give such
a nice talk on the optimization side of
matrix completion right before lunch it
really is a good segue into what I'm
going to talk about so I want to start
with you know very quickly go go through
the sort of older classical results on
on matrix completion which are now ten
years old or so so we know the setup is
that there's some matrix M we don't know
it but we can see some entries of the
matrix and we want to exactly recover
complete the hidden entries from only a
few entries that we see a common
assumption to make the problem well
posed and which models real types of
matrices in the world is that M has low
rank so if I'm gonna assume for this
talk that the matrix is square just so
one fewer parameter but everything here
extends to rectangular matrices also so
an N by n matrix which is rank R means
that it's degenerate in some sense it
has a skinny singular value
decomposition and essentially only has
on the order of two times n times our
degrees of freedom as opposed to n
squared degrees of freedom because of
this reduced number of degrees of
freedom we can imagine that we could
complete such a matrix given only the
knowledge that its rank are from on the
order of n times are revealed entries
and that's where the story starts of
course we know that the low rank
assumption is is not strong enough there
the canonical or something similar to
the bad example where we have a rank two
matrix which just has two ones and zeros
everywhere else this is a rank two
matrix and we're never going to see the
two nonzero entries of the matrix from a
number of samples that's order n times R
let alone less than N squared over two
okay so in the setting where we are
oblivious to everything except that the
matrix is low rank that's not going to
work we have to add an additional
structural assumption and a common one
is that the matrix is not only low rank
but incoherent so in coherence and
matrix completion has evolved a little
bit from from the beginning and now the
the the usual assumptions of event
coherence are more simple than than they
were previously what we mean by
incoherent is if we look at the matrix M
and it's skinny SVD decomposition that
if we look at the nut left and right
leverage scores
these are n left leverage scores and n
right leverage scores and the ice left
leverage score is just the angle between
the left singular subspace associated to
M with the ice canonical direction okay
so it measures how aligned that the
matrix is on the left with the ice
canonical basis vector and same for the
right singular okay so an additional
structural assumption
besides low rank is that the underlying
matrix has uniformly flat leverage
scores and that's more or less what
incoherence in matrix completion is so
uniformly flat leverage scores according
to this normalization means that all of
the leverage scores of the matrix are
essentially on the order of R divided by
n that's the normalization times times a
constant K so this is a very special
situation
because in fact the maximum value of K
can be n divided by R the leverage
scores can go up to one as in this bad
example where we have we have to
leverage scores equal to one and the
rest equal to zero okay so this
uniformly flat assumption is a very very
strong structural assumption but on the
other hand it's not as strong as the
original incoherence assumptions and
matrix completion were I just want to
point out something that matrices of
this type are incoherent just block
diagonal matrices where the values where
the blocks are the same sizes and the
values of the entries of the matrix can
be different on the different blocks so
that's a perfectly incoherent rank R
where R is number of blocks matrix so we
don't have to have like a Gaussian
random matrix or anything like that but
just a sense that all of the rows and
all of the columns are equally important
in some sense are balanced if the blocks
in this matrix were vastly different
sizes then we would become more and more
coherent the leverage scores have become
more unbalanced we've asked many
questions at any point so this is for a
constant number of blocks right this is
for our blocks so R is the rank and so
if you do the calculation then you get
that all of the leverage scores are R
over N so as small as they can be
okay so after many works and probably
more that I I couldn't mention here I
think most recently with you dong Chen
in 2013 we have the following sort of
uniform sampling matrix completion
result given an N by n matrix M of rank
R if we reveal entries of the matrix in
a very oblivious random fashion where
each entry is observed independently
with a probability P go through the
matrix to do that and we consider for
example the nuclear norm minimization
problem which is semi definite
optimization problem the relaxation of
finding the matrix of minimal rank
agreeing with the measurements this will
exactly recover or complete the
underlying matrix with high probability
provided that P the probability that we
sample any given entry is greater than
or equal to the maximum among all of the
leverage scores of the matrix times the
universal constant times log squared n
so remember that in the best case this
max Li RJ is on the order R over N in
the worst case it's order 1 so in
particular what this implies for the
sample complexity is that the expected
size or expected number of entries under
this sampling model is on the order of P
times n squared which is the max
leverage score times N squared times log
squared n so you see that in the worst
case when the leverage scores are very
unbalanced this gives us nothing that
says we have to sample the entire matrix
in the best case when the leverage
scores are flat this says order R times
n times log squared n entries is
sufficient and we know that that's
optimal in terms of the degrees of
freedom of the underline class up to the
log squared n term
so for the remainder of this talk I'm in
a regard log squared n is a constant
meaning I'm going to talk about results
that use this result and if the log
squared n term can be removed in this
result then they can be removed in those
results almost surely one of these login
factors is not necessary but I don't
think that that's been improved in this
general setting and again I'm not
advocating that we use nuclear nor
minimization with CP X on your laptop
there are many faster alternative
algorithms like non convex algorithms
operating on the factored matrix that
should have the same or comparable
performance questions note one thing is
that the condition number of the matrix
M does not appear anywhere in the
conditions the condition number of the
matrix is independent and independent
structure from the leverage scores of
the matrix so the matrix can be as ill
conditioned as possible as long as this
rank R and that doesn't change change
this
okay so we want to ask there's this
obvious or not obvious but there's
clearly a relationship between the the
model of sampling entries of the matrix
iid uniformly and requiring some
structural assumption like uniformly
flat leverage scores so more generally
what relationship can we say between the
leverage scores of a low rank matrix and
an optimal sampling strategy and that
led us to take a closer look at how the
sampling strategy is connected to the
leverage scores so again remember that
the the leverage scores are just the
angles of the left and right subspaces
of the matrix with each of the n
coordinate directions or just the norms
of the each of the n rows of U and V so
if an Oracle told us bounds on these
quantities these numbers Li and RJ gave
us sort of this information about the
matrix then you can imagine we might
want to sample entries from a weighted
probability distribution where we're
going to sample an entry IJ with higher
probability if it's more important
meaning that the sum of its the row and
the column leverage score associated
that entry is higher so this is general
idea behind important sampling and
designing optimal sampling distributions
for like Monte Carlo sampling and and
things like that so maybe not
necessarily Li + RJ maybe LA Times RJ
but something something like this in
particular for the bad example on slide
2 this would say we're just gonna sample
that corner with the ones and the matrix
more frequently and these leverage
scores although only more recently
introduced than the Matrix completion
problem one sided leverage scores have a
long history in the column or row subset
selection problem for matrix sketching
which the older problem where you have a
low rank matrix and you can sub sample
columns or rows of the matrix and you
want a good
set of columns that gives you a good
representation of an entire matrix and
they're a good way to sample columns is
according to one sided leverage scores
of that of that matrix
okay so what we did is we generalize the
the matrix completion result so we
assume we have a low rank matrix m and
an oracle has given us bounds on its
leverage scores so we know Li and RJ and
so we can derive a good way to sample
that matrix so its entry the IJ entry of
the matrix is we observe it
independently with the probability pIJ
which is greater than or equal to the
sum of the 8th of its corresponding row
and column leverage scores times again
log squared n and universal constant C
so if I Jason trees is is sampled
according to this a probability greater
than this then we can recover complete
the underlying matrix from these samples
and an expectation the number this
number of samples is on the order of R
times n times log squared n times
constant C so now we've removed any
dependence on the coherence factor and
this is you know as as few measurements
as we could hope to have to take to
recover a low rank matrix up to the log
squared n okay and the of course the
uniformly flat leverage score uniform
sampling is a special case of this of
this theorem and the key idea is to
refine the sort of dual certificate type
proof for matrix completion where we
derive concentration results with
respect to a weighted L to infinity
matrix norm instead of entry wise L
infinity norm so just more refined
concentration bounds on a uh norm that's
tied more closely to the spectral norm
of the matrix
this is still several years old so for
several years I guess it's been more
than three years I thought well this is
nice but this of course this theorem
requires still a lot of knowledge that
we know the leverage scores of underling
matrix so I guess in some settings you
could imagine that it could you could
have some bounds on leverage scores they
could be learned as they priors from
some class of training matrices that
you're interested in but typically and
this is very strong and we would like to
assume that we we don't have any
information about the leverage scores a
priori so the natural question is if
we're still in the setting where we can
just learn about the underlying matrix
by taking revealing entries of the
matrix is it possible to learn the
leverage scores of the matrix along the
way while completing it in a way where
the total sample complexity or the total
number of samples we need results in a
lower number than the number of samples
we would need just from uniformly iid
sampling of the matrix and that seems
possible given that we're asking for
only two end pieces of information to
and leverage scores versus two times n
times our degrees of freedom which is to
complete the entire matrix and it could
seem even more plausible that this could
be possible because if you look at the
at the result we only need a we only
need to bound the highest leverage
scores the largest leverage scores of
the matrix because if we sample from a
probability that's greater than the
little leverage scores that's fine it
doesn't matter
so the unimportant rows on columns we
don't need to know so in fact we just
need estimates for the large leverage
scores so we we would like to try to do
this to see if we can can adaptively
sample so that we can learn the leverage
scores and complete a matrix
and beat the number of samples one would
get from the uniform sampling founder so
our first try at a sort of adaptive or
two-phase low rank matrix completion
algorithm is as follows
just given a budget of M samples that we
can take and a parameter between zero
and one
first just draw em one entries of the
matrix via the uniform sampling model
okay because we're oblivious and we
don't know anything except we're
assuming the matrix is rank R so then
from the zero filled sample matrix
construct find the pits best rank our
approximation because you can only take
leverage scores of a low rank matrix the
leverage scores of a full rank matrix
are there always one do you have
orthonormal you Sigma B or orthonormal
so so take the rank R approximation to
the sort of the zero filled sample
matrix and then we have sort of
estimates of the leverage scores of the
underlying matrix and then from these
estimates generate a second batch of
measurements a second batch of entries M
2 according to the weighted distribution
given by these estimates and then we've
taken a number of samples and in total
and throw all of these samples and to
say nuclear noir minimization and
complete the matrix and see what happens
and so we found that gamma equals 0.75
seemed to be a good choice corresponding
to adding more samples allocated to the
phase one uniform sampling and I have
this very sad sad little picture
it's really embarrassing ly sad but it's
all I have so I'm gonna show it anyway
this was a typical simulation result we
we looked at 400 by 400 rank 10 matrices
that had a power loss structure so of
the form D times u times V transpose
times T where u and V are tall thin iid
Gaussian matrices so that would create a
roughly incoherent matrix but then we
reweighed the rows and columns by D a
diagonal matrix with power-law entries
so when the power alpha in the diagonal
matrix is 0 we just have an incoherent
matrix and when it's 1 we have a pretty
pretty coherent matrix and then we did
the two-phase matrix completion
algorithm on the previous page and we
looked for the oversampling factor we
need in order for matrix completion to
work with high probability and so as the
coherence increases we see that we do
need more samples with the two-phase
sampling but the sample complexity is
far far better than what uniform
sampling needs so uniform sampling
really really becomes very bad when the
matrix is coherent and then I don't know
but you see this black line which is the
sort of Oracle distribution leverage
score sampling which is what we would
need if we knew the leverage scores a
priori okay so this suggests that it you
know adaptive sampling and matrix
completion can really help in reducing
the complexity when the assumption of n
coherence is violated so we wanted to
look into this but unfortunately we
could not derive any theory any theory
for this all of the results in the
literature we found on you know how how
good estimates of leverage storage and
get of a matrix from its samples
none of those results were strong enough
to prove that this could lead to smaller
sample complexity than uniform sampling
just the
but then we remembered oh but for for
matrix completion we don't need tests
they made all the leverage scores just
just the large ones we just need to know
the large ones so we looked at a
different algorithm that's simpler to
simpler to understand at least for me
but not really the algorithm that you
want to use so keep that in mind so if
we have our low rank matrix or rank our
matrix M and it has now I'm bringing the
condition number in to the talk which I
didn't want to but alas the condition
number the ratio of the largest over the
smallest singular values of the matrix
then there's a relationship between the
squared l 2-norm of the 8th row of the
matrix and its eyes leverage score so
the l2 norm of the I throw of the matrix
is always going to be less than or equal
to five levels four times the largest
single herb I squared and it's going to
be greater than or equal to the ice
leverage squared times the smallest
singular value squared so in the ideal
setting when the matrix has condition
number one and as long as you know the
norm of the matrix you get all of the
leverage scores exactly from the row and
column norms
so that's that's that's one so so we're
going to use row and column norms of the
sampled matrix to estimate leverage
scores and just from this alone you see
that it's only going to to do well if
the underlying matrix is well
conditioned so there's going to be a
condition number that appears in the
estimate that is an artifact of this
algorithm which isn't really the right
algorithm that you want to do so then we
considered the two-phase sampling
algorithm which is just the same as
before except now we draw uniform
samples from the matrix and then we
construct estimates of the leverage
scores just by looking at the squared L
two norms of the rows and the columns of
the resulting zero filled sample matrix
properly normalized so we're using these
as our estimates for leverage scores and
then from those estimates we construct
weighted sampling distribution and then
draw a second batch of samples according
to that weighted distribution
so we can prove some things about about
this algorithm so we're going to look at
the just write the leverage scores the
left and right leverage scores and
decreasing rearrangement that's why I
put the parentheses around 1 2 and N so
assume they're in decreasing
rearrangement we can say that if the
phase one sampling probability so the
probability that you sample an entry in
the the first phase where we do uniform
sampling is greater than this number
which has the dependence on the
condition number Kappa times the minimum
of this quantity over a parameter T from
1 to n then with nice probability the
estimated leverage scores will be
bounded above and below by the
underlying true leverage scores at least
the largest T of them ok so if T equals
1 then we essentially just recover the
standard sample complexity from uniform
sampling matrix completion but if T is a
little bit larger than 1 you can see
that we get a gain because the leverage
scores are numbers that are less than 1
so the square of a number that's less
than 1 is smaller than the number so
what this says is well if there are only
a small number of the leverage scores
row and column leverage scores that are
bigger than the rest of them then we can
estimate those few big ones and gain a
factor and the sample complexity that
will be smaller than the sample
complexity matrix completion because
those big numbers get squared here so
they get squashed down and only the T
plus 1st largest leverage score
into play without a square in the sample
complexity so this looks a little bit
crazy so let's look at some what this
implies for the two-phase matrix
completion algorithm what it implies for
the algorithm is that if we use this
number of samples for the phase one
sampling and then if we can get those
estimates of leverage scores we only
need on the order of n times R times log
squared n samples for Phase two the
weighted sampling then together those
samples will be sufficient to recover
the rank R matrix M with a good
probability so you see here the
bottleneck is in the phase one sampling
and some special cases are okay
uniformly flat leverage scores this
means that all the leverage scars are on
the order R over N so up to the
dependence on the condition number our
sampling complexity matches just the
standard n times R log squared n result
so it recovers that result as a special
case there are some other cases we could
look at if the first the largest T
leverage scores left and right leverage
scores are on the order of square root R
over N I think of this as a medium
coherence range and the remaining
leverage scores are uniformly small R
over n then this adaptive sampling we
still only need on the order of n times
R times log squared n samples multiplied
by the T the number of larger leverage
scores so in this medium coherence range
we can get a sample complexity from
adaptive sampling that's much smaller
than what you would get by just doing
uniform sampling
and then more generally we can look at
matrices whose leverage scores have a
power law type distribution just one
particular example is this the largest
so many leverage scores are decaying at
a rate of like AI to the three halves
but this could be any rate greater than
1 then this sample complexity is on the
order of n to the 4/3 whereas the sample
complexity you get from uniform sampling
is on the order of n to the three halves
so the sample complexity is produced and
I have some some simulations so these
are just pictures of for the four
different power law type matrices that
I'm going to to look at experiments for
so I don't know if you can even see but
this this matrix over here is very very
coherent almost all of its energy is is
just over here so it has very very fast
power lot-ek
and then we have a matrix that's a
little more diffuse a matrix that is
almost incoherent but but but still has
some bias leverage scores and then a
sort of classical incoherent incoherent
matrix and if you can see here I'm
plotting the probability of exact
recovery and plotting sort of the phase
transitions for uniform sampling versus
the to face sampling and if you can't
see the results are just what you would
expect that as we get more and more
coherent the two-phase sampling diverges
from the uniform sampling and can do
much much better or complete matrices
using fewer samples and then this is
just the average sampling probability
over here so here the condition number
is 1 in all of these but we tried again
with the same types of matrices except
now condition number 100 and
surprisingly found that the
results were the same as when the
condition number was one so even when
the condition number is 100 the
two-phase sampling results in the
ability to complete a low rate matrix
for many fewer samples than uniform
sampling and the plots almost looked
unchanged so this was suggest that even
this algorithm that we're using doesn't
depend on the condition number of
underlying matrix that much and then we
considered different types of low rank
matrices so here's just a block diagonal
matrix so it's rank 5 and I don't know
if you can see this but this is rank 4
and it has it's a block diagonal matrix
or the blocks are very different sizes
so this has this is incoherent and this
is more coherent and you see that for
the completely incoherent matrix uniform
sampling does a little better because
uniform sampling is optimal sampling
probability when you're incoherent so
two-face does slightly worse but for the
coherent block diagonal matrix two-face
sampling does better than the uniform
sampling and then we increase the
condition number and looked still so
increasing the condition number
here corresponds to changing the values
of the blocks to making the values more
dynamic and here the two-phase matrix
completion did worse than the uniform
matrix completion even though when we
look at the sort of reconstruction error
they they look about the same
but uniform matrix completion can
complete exactly from fewer samples so
this is a case where we do worse so I'm
showing you good results and results
where where we do worse but I do want to
emphasize that the two-phase type of
adaptive sampling fundamentally cannot
do that much worse than uniform sampling
because just from the first batch of
uniform samples especially if you use
most of your budget for the uniform
samples you'll do at least as well as
the matrix completion theory from those
uniform samples you're just adding an
additional batch of samples drawn from a
weighted distribution and if your guess
on that weighted distribution is bad
then you'll do about as well as uniform
sampling with the uniform samples if
it's good then you have the ability to
to do much better than if you took all
your samples uniformly so again the just
to review we have sort of the classical
matrix completion result says that a new
rank our matrix can be completed from a
number of uniform samples n squared
times the maximum leverage score and
this is good
when all the leverage scores are
uniformly flat more generally if we knew
what the leverage scores were in advance
then we can come up with a weighted
sampling strategy that requires only on
the order of n times our samples to
complete the matrix but this requires
that we have this prior knowledge which
is unrealistic so we looked at a
two-phase sampling procedure which first
samples on treats uniformly and then
estimation leverage scores from those
samples and then draws samples from a
different distribution
and showed basically sample complexity
for this algorithm which always at least
matches the sample complexity from
uniform sampling up to a constant and
condition number but can also lead to
sample complexity that's much much lower
whether it's optimally low I don't know
I don't know what what lower bounds are
for for these types of results but
future directions are definitely to
improve the dependence on the condition
number the experiments suggest that
there's some very mild dependence of the
two-phase sampling on the condition
number theory for noisy under nearly low
rank matrices of the same type that we
have for the standard matrix completion
and maybe more broadly extensions to
other types of flavors of these
algorithms reduce sample complexity if
we have some sparsity and into a
coherence and measurements any any of
these types of problems to see if
adaptive sampling can reduce the sample
complexity in any of those those
settings as well
[Applause]
to face is that an agent - rotating
logon pages into another next time again
actuated very mentally we didn't see in
any any gains from using more than two
phases so I think that there could be a
gain if you do something more clever in
the different phases than just uniform
weighted updated weighted updated
there's probably some way to do a more
clever combination or alternation than
what what we tested tested for
[Applause]